my man is up for an Oscar for the
holdovers look at you good to see you
Paul nice to see you it's been a long
time I had to show you this first of all
you're not going to believe me you're
going to think I made this up do you see
this picture yeah of us on the set of
private parts doing the famous scene
where we go WN B yeah I have this
picture right outside my studio so when
I walk in in the morning that's the last
thing I look at like as I walk into the
studio believe it or not great at the
time I didn't realize how what an
opportunity this was to work with an
actor of your caliber well it was an
opportunity for me that's why I mean I
think I I'd never done anything like
this on film either like I hadn't done
this much on film so I was nervous too
and I want to screw it up and you were
effortless so it actually made it easy
for me because all of you guys were it
it was easy for me I didn't know what I
was doing on film really either you know
and I didn't realize I didn't realize
you were 30 years old at that point and
this was your first sort of major motion
picture I mean you had to be like like
that had to be a really important moment
for you because you're 30 years old and
most actors have done some sort of film
where I mean you had done little Parts
yeah little things I mean so it must
have been a huge break for you to be
yeah I didn't realize any of this but
the whole thing was exciting I mean
getting to do it with you getting to do
anything like this at all and the part
was great I've talked to Mary mccor who
played my wife in the movie and she was
like full of angst about doing the movie
because of my reputation and thinking
you know whether or not she should do it
yeah and Stanley Tucci who she had
worked with said to her she said I don't
know if this will hurt my film career
and he looked at her and went what film
career you don't have a film career go
through the movie absolutely I had the
same thing some of my agents were like
really you want to do this I was like
yes I want to do it first of all it's a
really good script and I was like and
who the hell am I who the hell cares and
it's like honestly like who cares and
I'm going to have fun doing it you know
isn't it amazing like like I I cuz I had
never asked you that before like your
agents some of them were like yeah maybe
should right you shouldn't be with movie
some of them some of them were concerned
but the main guy that I worked with
wasn't at all he thought it was great
when my agent saw your work this is when
you were you know 30 years old and no
one knew you were my agent turned to me
and said you're going to be a huge star
he says out of everybody in that old
[__] crew it's going to be Paul
giamani so he knew right away which was
unbelievable that's nice he said it
about Mary McCormick too but but he he
was very focused on you wanted to
represent you the whole thing you know
yeah now I remember that yeah yeah he
told me that at the time yeah he thought
you were great cuz Paul nailed this guy
was a real life guy and Paul nailed this
guy it was weird so when I did the
scenes I felt like I was working with
the real pig virus right Betty Thomas
was great she let me just do whatever I
wanted to do which was amazing but I
went in five times or something for her
but I got to know like what she was like
she got to know what I was like and then
you know it takes care of a lot of
problems before you get to yeah you know
no that's no [__] I remember because
they would come to me and say uh you
know Betty would come to me and say we
we found this guy to play um you know
Pig virus but we called them Pig vomit
in the movie and I I I said really I
said let me look at this and I looked
and I was like whoa this is great I
remember watching it and I go what
what's the problem let's well I got to
be sure I got to be sure she kept saying
you know I got to be sure but I was like
I'm sure I like this but I remember the
other guy was Philip Seymour hman who
was up for that that's right he would
have been great he would have been
amazing he would have been amazing why
did they why did you call him Pig vomit
and not Pig virus somebody just asked me
this the other day and I didn't I never
knew because when I wrote my book they
wanted me to change all the names of
people like first girl friends or this
or that or the other thing so that
people I guess wouldn't sue you or
something he could so I was like you
really I guess I got to change the name
to Pig vomit from Pig virus I wanted him
to be Pig I mean it doesn't make any
sense now it's funny they could he have
done that's very funny like it was
trademarked or something Pig got like
yeah I don't even know it was just so
weird and and it bothered me that you
were Pig vomit not Pig it was Pig virus
because yeah yeah yeah yeah there was a
kid at my summer camp we called Pig
virus and I thought that was the
greatest thing and when I was on the
radio one day I was like sitting there
and I'm on NBC I'm on this big radio and
I go where's my boss Pig virus you know
yeah Paul it's uh it's so good seeing
you I have such wonderful feelings about
you because I wish I could go back in
time and save her yeah me too even you
and I being on set together yeah me too
and and and take it all in I think reg
but that one for sure yeah I feel like I
did I did feel a lot I remember that
every second of making that movie in a
way and it's like more so than other
things I think I did Savor that one
because it was the whole thing was great
yeah you got to win that [__] hosp
man I'd be so proud of you cuz you know
in a way I feel like sort of in your
career responsible in some small way I I
say that I'm not kidding that I say I
credit you totally have you already
fantasized what your speech is going to
be if you get I mean I keep thinking I
have to have something to say but I have
no idea what I would do I have no idea
what I would say no it's going to be
great if you uh it' be nice yeah well
I'll I I'll thank you that I'll do that
for sure
yeah sure absolutely [__] you mean at
the Academy Awards sure you're saying
you're going to thank me if I win that
thing I would thank you yes son of a
[__]